on prime crime sheriff's office who's
inside
watch our asses john it's a scene that
left officers shocked
and saw that there was some legs on the
ground saw that there was blood i saw
the guy who was missing half his face a
race to find
a missing girl any child comes up
messing
and pisses me off my first thoughts were
i mean it was like i was literally
seeing a ghost
and the evil behind it all there is no
doubt
in my mind that you are one of the most
dangerous man to ever walk
on this planet
hey everybody i'm jesse weber and
welcome to prime crime
this is where we do a deeper dive into
the most high profile and memorable true
crime cases
several years ago the nation was
captivated by an unspeakable crime and
kidnapping
and what would unfold we're still trying
to explain
what you're hearing is the frantic call
police received on october 15
2018 the call originated from the cell
phone of denise claus from barron county
wisconsin
the denise claus 911 call is absolutely
chilling
you don't hear a whole lot of
explanation here's some words
but you mainly hear the chaos that's
going on
then there's quiet
officers rushed to the home of denise
her husband james
and their 13 year old daughter jamie
open door
somebody's down somebody's sheriff's
office who's inside
watch our asses john when authorities
arrive just
minutes after the 911 call they find a
gruesome sight
we got a dead body in this one
we got a body in here too james and
denise kloss
are shot dead dead body right at the
front door
heavy trauma to the face gunshot looks
like a shotgun shell in the face
there's one shell expended shell next to
the body
found another one in the in the bathroom
almost directly straight back from the
front door
in the bathtub dead as for jamie
door's been breached we're missing
somebody
she's nowhere to be found we're still
missing a gun
we're missing a lot a widespread search
for the missing teenager ensues
with the fbi even offering a reward of
25
thousand dollars for information leading
to jamie's whereabouts
there were search teams put together
there were thousands of tips rolling in
ninety five percent of those tips end up
being nothing
canvasing knocking on doors they did not
exhaust
one means to try to find their answer we
statistically know
that every hour that passes in a
situation like this where a child is
abducted
the chance of finding them alive goes
down two people who brutally murdered
and
and she was taken from the house i mean
there isn't higher stakes than that ever
about a week later as jamie's parents
are laid to rest
a startling development authorities are
alerted to someone breaking into the
claws home
the burglar is apprehended and id'd as
32 year old
kyle janki annis in all reality they
it was her underwear or something like
that
any any child comes up this and it
pisses me off
and it makes me want to go you know
jankianis turns out to not be the killer
just a common criminal who wanted to
steal some things
turns out to be a massive red herring
but it drains
very important resources in manpower at
a time when you can't afford to
be diverted from the intention of the
investigation
at the national center for missing and
exploited children
we were wondering the same thing is
jamie out there
is she even alive as the days went
on media attention at least nationally
started to go down we're strategizing
behind the scenes trying to figure out
you know what we could do i had plans to
go out to wisconsin
and see if we could bring more attention
uh
to jamie's case unfortunately for
investigators in the kloss family
with each passing day the outcome for
jamie
is getting worse and worse
douglas county 9-1-1 hi i
have a young lady at my house right now
and she just says her name is jamie
cloth
on january 10 2019 over two months after
the killings
jamie closs is suddenly found alive in
gordon wisconsin
an hour away from baron okay have you
seen her photo ma'am
for 88 days i have stood before you and
said we would work tirelessly
to bring jamie claus home today i can
report we have done just that
when we heard the news that jamie was
found
i i can't even describe it to you what
happened at the national center
we were stunned it was emotional we were
happy according to the caller kristen
kozinkis
her neighbor jeannie nutter found kloss
she gets on the phone
and explains what happened so how did
she come up upon your cabin
i was walking my dog and we were almost
home
and she was walking towards me crying
saying you gotta help me you gotta help
me
jamie's ability to escape in this case
is is
amazing to me i mean all too often and
unfortunately most of the time we don't
have a positive resolution like this
it's really through the resilience and
the courage
of the person who's escaped when i saw
her i knew
she was in trouble because i knew she
had wherever she came from she left in a
hurry because she just had on
a sweatshirt and leggings and
shoes that were too big for her it's
rare to have somebody
found alive after 48 hours in missing
person cases
because the trail dries up very quickly
if you're not able to find
something within that period of time
time and distance
works against police officers so 88 days
is
incredibly remarkable my first thoughts
were i
i basically went into shock i mean it
was like i was literally seeing a ghost
i told jamie when she was sitting on my
couch yesterday just said i am so glad
to see you
jamie was able to escape but from who
jamie
[Music]
patterson a then 21 year old
after nutter identifies the suspect
patterson's quickly located by police
while in his car
and immediately says i did it but when
he's thrown in the back of a cruiser
listen to the odd exchange between him
and the officer ah
you're no longer detained you're under
arrest now okay
for what oh they'll tell you when they
get up to the officer
someone gonna turn off my car yeah do
something with it the other officer i'll
take care of it for you
it's gonna be a little bit of a drive so
if you want to get comfy
on some level he's confused he's in
shock
even though he knew this probably would
be the end
of how it all turned out soon after his
arrest
patterson not only admits to police that
he kidnapped jamie and murdered her
parents
but he voluntarily provides additional
dark
details i think jake patterson almost
immediately confessed because
he knew that if jamie ever escaped
he was done for i mean there's no debate
about what happened
there's no chance of him trying to
explain this away
we would learn he became infatuated with
the 13 year old
after randomly seeing her getting on a
school bus
it seems to me like he had this thing of
wanting to
abduct someone a child and
you know this presented the opportunity
for it he something
clicked in him and it flipped a switch
and that was the moment
through patterson's admission we got a
clear picture of what was happening
on that 911 phone call by his own
admission i think he was only in that
house for four minutes or so
so to carry out this entire thing that
quickly
it tells me that he had an objective he
knew what he was doing
he had a purpose and a focus he needed
to kill the father first because that's
the biggest threat you're going to have
he actually shot james through the
window point blank
before shooting the front door kicking
it down and then
trying to find where jamie was he ended
up busting through
into the bathroom and finding them both
in the tub with a mother trying to
protect her at that point
investigators then realized that
patterson had slipped through their
fingers
let's go back to deputy john fick's dash
cam as he rushes to the claws home on
the night of the murders
notice the car on the left that was jake
patterson
driving with a stolen license and jamie
tied up in the trunk
something officers even picked up on at
the time
that one car was heading out as we were
coming
but they yielded on camera camera yep
the cars going that way that maroon car
that yielded
yeah you're right
[Music]
you know we all want to say you know
darn it that he should have been caught
the police were that close but remember
the police had just received a call
from the house that an act of violence
was taking place
so their main focus was on getting to
that house as quick as they could
patterson actually pulls off to the
shoulder to let the police pass which is
what most people
do so he didn't do anything out of the
ordinary
i downloaded the video i still i
couldn't get anything like
the headlights were blocking and i don't
even know if even had a front license
plate
you know it's just one of those real
unfortunate things that they didn't have
the manpower
to dispatch someone to follow or get on
that car
and respond to the scene at the same
time
when we come back we're going to get
into the details of jamie's captivity
and we hear from patterson himself
mr patterson not only were you a danger
to the kloss family
[Music]
but then i shined it again and saw that
there was some legs on the ground saw
that there was blood
open the door and
said that i saw the guy who was missing
half his face
back on january 10 2019
thirteen-year-old jamie closs
stunned the world by miraculously
escaping the home of jake patterson the
man who had murdered her parents in cold
blood
and held her hostage for months now
patterson immediately confessed
and we would then gain greater insight
into the kidnapping
and his mind what exactly happened
though during jaime's 88 days of
imprisonment
according to patterson he kept the girl
locked in his cabin
at times forcing her under his bed for
hours with no
food water or bathroom breaks they would
play board games
watch tv and would even sleep in the
same bed
friends of his have said during that
time frame they noticed
an uptick in his personality that he was
friendly and he was seen to be happier
um so i think in his warped mind
he was forming a life together with
jaime and they were going to
i don't know maybe live happily ever
after in this
particular case it was about power and
control combined
knowing that he had somebody who was
young and immature
that he could have power over and she
could do whatever he wants her to do
patterson though never thought jamie
would actually try to escape
you know obviously jamie is under this
tremendous fear and is using that fear
in the beginning
to keep her captive he doesn't have to
do much
to make her more fearful of him because
of what she witnessed
at her own house that night i think for
her she just
kept it together every day she didn't
know
when she was going to get out or if she
ever was going to
it must have taken everything inside her
to just
take that moment and run
i can't even say enough about how brave
and courageous she was that day
patterson claims though despite his
obsession with jaime
he never sexually assaulted her it was
never about
the sexuality of it i think it was about
the companionship
and having somebody that he can have
hold accountable to him
since the district attorney in that area
decided not to prosecute
any charges that related to behavior of
those 88 days
they decided not to put jamie through
any kind of investigation
so we really won't ever really know what
happened during those 88 days in full
detail
patterson's charged with intentional
homicide kidnapping
and armed burglary as he sat in jail
awaiting trial
he stuns the public by writing a letter
to a local reporter
once again providing more answers into
what he was thinking
the cops say i planned this thoroughly
and that i said that
they're really good at twisting your
words around put them in different spots
straight up lie little mad about that
trying to cover up their mistakes i
guess
this was mostly on impulse i don't think
like a serial killer
i think patterson writing the letter to
the local reporter was his way of
letting the public
know what was happening in his head
it was an atrocious act now it's his
time to say you know what
yeah i did this but for the reason
is because of these issues that he has
when asked what was going through his
mind when he started perpetrating the
crime
patterson said he was angry and didn't
want to do it
but the reason i did this is complicated
patterson ends up not fighting the
charges how do you plead to that charge
guilty guilty
guilty i think that he knew he couldn't
beat the charges and he wanted it over
as soon as possible
in his warped mind again he did voice
some concern about
not wanting to put jamie through a trial
he put her through so much
right the horrific things that he did to
her and now he has some kind of
famed concern you know i'm not a
psychologist but i think that
you know some of that might have been
genuine
at patterson's sentencing it became a
question of whether or not this man
could ever get a chance at parole
we would hear powerful victim impact
statements but in one of the most
dramatic moments a family attorney reads
a statement
from jamie closs i don't want to even
see
my home or my stuff because of the
memory of that night
my parents in my home were the most
important things in my life
he took them away from me in a way that
will always leave me with a horrifying
memory
but there are some things that jake
patterson can never take from me
he can't take my freedom he thought that
he could own me but he was wrong
i was smarter i watched his routine and
i took back my freedom
i will always have my freedom and he
will not
her family members now who are helping
raise her
gave her the strength to say that she
will not let this
influence the way she lives the rest of
her life that she will be happy
going forward and that he's going to be
in her rear view mirror so
i think it's extremely powerful you know
the fact that he tried to take things
from her and he did take things from her
but he couldn't take
away who she was i saw it as a very
remarkable young woman
then patterson has some final words
himself
i would do like absolutely anything
to take back what i did you know
i would die i would
do absolutely anything
[Music]
to bring them back nope
i don't care about me i just
[Music]
i'm just so sorry that's
i think patterson apologizing and crying
and tearing up
was again another another manipulation
whether or not he
felt terrible about it he said he wanted
to go back in time and he wished he
didn't kill her parents
and you wish he wasn't in that situation
well of course not he's going to jail
for the rest of his life
then it's judge james badler's turn and
he doesn't hold
anything back your actions and
the ideas
that you had are not normal
they are shockingly not normal
i have no idea what rehabilitation could
be provided for you no one suggested any
rehabilitation
because even from your own side the
doctors can't find anything wrong with
you
for a judge to use the harsh language
that he did you know clearly indicates
he was horrified
by the events that took place in that
house that night and subsequent to that
night
and these crimes rank as the most
heinous and dangerous that i have seen
either here or anywhere else in the
state of wisconsin
and perhaps the united states
at one point judge babler read aloud the
words of patterson
but the defendant wasn't happy she was
the first girl i saw once i had those
ideas in my head
mr patterson not only were you a danger
to the closs family
and that was his way of exerting his
last morsel of
power in that setting in order to show
the public that
again he is in charge there is no doubt
in
my mind that you are one of the most
dangerous men to ever walk
on this planet babbler sentenced
patterson
to two life terms without the
possibility of parole
plus an additional 40 years
today was a very important step in the
process of helping jamie to move forward
we are satisfied with the outcome and
believe that it will give jamie
some much needed peace of mind as jake
patterson spends the rest of his life
behind bars wrestling with the decisions
he made
he may also have to wrestle to save his
life
in video obtained from the new mexico
corrections department
patterson seen getting into a physical
altercation with another inmate after he
reportedly was harassed
for the crimes he committed against a
minor it's typical
when an offender abuses children
there's some kind of jailhouse
code that if they get in contact with
somebody who is incarcerated for those
things they're going to make it known
that that it's unacceptable and a lot of
times those people end up dead
as for jamie her aunt and guardian
jennifer smith says
she's doing good surrounded by loved
ones and is taking life
day by day jamie will very likely have
more
to say in the future but we are grateful
for you allowing her to do that
on her own terms i've been involved in
a couple of recoveries of this type in
my career
and i think that in this case
the possibility of jamie moving on with
her life
is strong she has proved herself to be
a very courageous very remarkable and
very resilient
young lady i just want people to
remember
that there are thousands of missing
children out there it's up to
us to make sure we're aware of the
missing children
in our community because we could be
that person to help
bring that child home at the time of
this taping we just passed the two-year
anniversary from when
jaime was found and as we look back it's
still hard to make sense of why all this
happened to her and maybe it'll never
make sense
but jamie's aunt released a statement on
the two-year mark
encouraging everyone to never take life
for granted
and that quote you never know what
tomorrow will bring
always remember to take the time to tell
your loved ones
you love them and maybe we just leave it
at that
that's all we have for you on prime
crime leave us your comments on
instagram and twitter with the hashtag
primecrime
as always thank you for joining us until
next time
be safe
[Music]
you